EITHER: NIEDERREITER WITH A
GOOD CHANCE.
AS SOON AS HE GOT BY THE NET HE.
PESCE BACK TO PLAY THE PUCK.
>> Kenny: HURRICANES HAVE SCORED
FIRST IN ALL FIVE GAMES.
LONG PASS UP THE RIGHT SIDE FOR
BRAD MARCHAND.
MOVING IN WITHY DeANGELO, I
BELIEVE, THAT MADE THET ALONG F
REDIRECTS IN THAT FIRST PERIOD
BY CAROLINA.
JARVIS OUT TO THE RIGHT SIDE PL
FOR THE HURRICANES TRAILING BY A
JARVIS WITH A SHOT.ALIVE.
KOTKANIEMI WITH  RAANTA.BACK OU
SWAYMAN IS GOING DOWN,THE BRUIN.
THEN BACK THE OTHER WAY.
THERE IS NECAS FOREHAND AND
BACKHAND AND SWAYMAN D
HERE IS McAVNCREDIBLE PASS BY
CHARLIE McAVOY WHOSE FIRST SHIFT
SINCE TAKING THA
NOW SLAVINLEFT.
SCORE!
-- WITHOUT AF
OF THE STICK OF KOTKANIEMI MINU
REMAINING ON THE POWER PLAY FOR
THY OF MY NAMED DEREK IS OUT.
NOW FOLIGNO FORCESS LAZAR TO CO.
WHAT A BEAUTIFULIN!
IT WENT PAST HIM!
>> Bryce: LOOKED LIKSWAYMAN AS
MOVES RIGHT-TO-LEFT.
A BRILLIAN